wir schauen jetzt mal wie es bei einer
möglichen regierungsbildung
momentan vorangeht heute nehmen nämlich
die 22 arbeitsgruppen ihre arbeit auf
und da fragen wir nach bei meinem
kollegen erhard scherfer in berlin er
hat was ist überhaupt bekannt darüber
wie das ganze ablaufen wird
th wildau man könnte sagen da sind sie
wieder unsere drei probleme wir wissen
noch nicht mal wer sich alles heute
trifft wir wissen nicht wo man sich
trifft und wir wissen auch nicht wann
man sich trifft
[Musik]
wir werden zügig durch kommen meint
volker wissing der generalsekretär der
fdp vor dem heutigen beginn der
koalitionsverhandlungen
koalitionsverhandlungen fangen jetzt an
sagen wir sind alle in vorfreude die
stimmung ist gut unser ziel ist es jetzt
sehr konzentriert zu arbeiten wir werden
den arbeitsgruppen viel abverlangen
konzentrierte arbeit viel einsatz und
präsenz das ist ein komplexes
unterfangen das wird sich sicherlich
auch mal verknoten alles andere würde
mich überraschen
verknoten kann sich noch so einiges denn
im sondierungs papier stecken noch
einige unklarheiten und unschärfen
beispiel 1 klimaschutz wer viel co2
verbraucht soll bald mehr zahlen wie und
wann dieser co2 preis steigt das wurde
wohlweislich ausgeklammert der
kohleausstieg soll vielleicht schon 2030
kommen aber nur idealer weise wie es
heißt
beispiel zwei außen- und
sicherheitspolitik zum verhältnis zu
china und russland kein wort vielleicht
weil die spd hier deutlich anders denkt
als grüne und fdp
die gaspipeline nord stream zwei von der
spd häufig verteidigt steht nicht direkt
im papier dafür ein bekenntnis zum
europäischen energie recht dass die
grünen als enorme hürde für das projekt
begreifen eine gemeinsame linie gibt es
nicht beim verteidigungsetat schaut man
konkrete zahlen und belässt es lieber
wenn allgemein lob für bundeswehr und
bündnisse die heißen kartoffeln die
themen und die keiner daran will ist
sowieso immer verteidigung das heißt
also die frage wie viel geld kriegen wir
eigentlich für die bundeswehr und
wieviel bundeswehr kriegen wir für das
geld das wird glaube ich die schwierige
rechnerei sein da werden sich die
deutschen in zukunft jetzt über die
blöcke beugen müssen uns sehen müssen
dass wahrscheinlich ohne eine erhöhung
des verteidigungshaushaltes die
bundeswehr in zwei drei jahren
schrumpfen wird beispiel 3 die
finanzierung stabile renten ökologischer
umbau noch am abend des sondierungs
papiers stellt die vorsitzende der ju
dazu eine entscheidende frage ich frage
mich wie das am ende alles finanziert
werden soll marco buschmann hat für die
fdp maßgeblich am papier mitgewirkt er
sagt alles was drinsteht sei ja auch
finanzierbar und änderungen bei der
besteuerung seien definitiv vom tisch
das bedeutet eben dass wir weder
einkommens noch mehrwertsteuer oder
unternehmenssteuer erhöhen werden und so
weiter dass wir diese instrumente eben
nicht brauchen sondern dass aus dem
laufenden haushalt heraus finanziert
bekommen auch franziska brantner von den
grünen lag mit verhandelt beim geld
richtet sie sich auf harte
verhandlungswochen ein sie halten das
alles was da drin steht für
gegenfinanzierung wir haben da jetzt
noch nicht ein endgültiges koalitions
verhandlungsergebnis das fängt ja jetzt
erst an und dann wird man am ende
sicherlich auch sehen wo noch mal die
prioritäten gesetzt werden noch vor
weihnachten soll die neue regierung
stehen und mit olaf scholz auf den
kanzlersessel sitzen noch ist es nicht
soweit erste sitzung mit den neuen
abgeordneten der zwanzigste bundestag
ist der größte aller zeiten bitte nehmen
sie platz der bisherige
parlamentspräsident hat nur abgeordnete
in den saal gelassen die chinesen
geimpft oder getestet sind erkennbar am
schwarz-rot-goldenen handgelenks band
wer kein nachweis bringen kann oder will
muss auf die tribüne
alle 23 sind von der afd dass
deutschland inzwischen nach china das
zweitgrößte parlament der welt hat ist
allen fraktionen irgendwie peinlich
es gibt an tag eins dieser wahlperiode
neue plätze zu sehen und neue
platzprobleme ganz hinten wo zum ersten
mal seit 70 jahren der südschleswigsche
wählerverband einen sitz hat und ganz
vorn wo die jedes mal neben der afd
niemand sitzen will nur dass diesmal die
fdp auf die ampel mehrheit zusteuert und
cdu/csu zum tauschen zwingen kann
gleich nach der wahl eine traditionelle
sitzordnung im plenum mit der
brechstange ändern zu wollen finde ich
es nicht gut das spiel und ich
spüre ein hauch von arroganz der macht
er tut den bisher mächtigen schulen wie
der machtwechsel der heutige
spd
bundestagsfraktion schlägt die kollegin
bärbel bars vor
auf bärbel bas die dritte
bundestagspräsidentin die erste seit
interviews mit werden 79,6 prozent
entfallen damit kommt sie offensichtlich
stimmen von allen seiten und blumen auch
ich habe nicht selbst den finger gehoben
das stimmt aber ich habe im richtigen
moment ja gesagt
neu unter den fünf vize präsidentin
yvonne mag was cdu aus sachsen und
alters spd aus hamburg das neue
bundestagspräsidium gruppenbild mit man
30 tage nach der bundestagswahl beginnt
etwas neues für die bundesregierung für
den bundestag für das deutsche vaterland
[Musik]
was genau kommt auf die deutschen zu was
wird sich ändern in politik wirtschaft
gesellschaft kaum zu sagen die
verhandler schweigsam blackbox
koalitionsverhandlungen
wie ist das für sie als politischer
korrespondent geht da auch etwas
verloren eine teilhabe an demokratischen
prozessen und die leute mitzunehmen und
legitimität zu schaffen
nun auf der einen seite ist natürlich
das ganze mit der hoffnung verbunden
dass man schnell und effizient
zueinander kommt auf der anderen seite
als journalist es ist natürlich völlig
unbefriedigend wenn man quasi keine
informationen verkaufen kann dann
entsteht das was auch sehr zu
kritisieren ist das nämlich nicht sauber
recherchiert wird eine quelle wenn
überhaupt und dann wird das als tatsache
in die welt geblasen
da muss man sehr vorsichtig sein als
journalist was man melden kann und was
nicht dann braucht man zwei quellen für
und gesicherte informationen und in fast
allen themenbereichen haben wir diese
zwei quellen nicht
zum glück wird einiges jedoch auch offen
ausdiskutiert beispiel die debatte um
das infektionsschutzgesetz der erste
gesetzentwurf den die ampel parteien ins
parlament einbringen ihr corona plan für
die nächsten monate es geht auch darum
handlungsfähigkeit zu demonstrieren
obwohl die koalitionsverhandlungen noch
laufen das virus ist noch unter uns und
bedroht die gesundheit der bürgerinnen
und bürger
und deshalb ist es ganz ganz wichtig
dass wir alle maßnahmen ergreifen um
sicher zu sein dass wir die gesundheit
der bürgerinnen und bürger unseres
landes schützen können auch wenn die
lage anders ist weil so viele geimpft
sind ist sie noch nicht gut
das land müsse winterfest gemacht werden
sagt er möglicherweise nächste kanzler
bis zum 19 märz sollen die länder
maßnahmen weiter anordnen können dass
die epidemische lage von nationaler
tragweite am 25 november ausläuft daran
wollen die ampel parteien allerdings
festhalten die union kritisierte die
entscheidung scharf was ist denn die
situation ist denn hier irgendjemand der
meinung dass kobelt nicht übertragbar
ist außer die afg ist irgend jemand der
meinung dass kobelt nicht bedrohlich ist
ist irgend jemand der meinung dass wir
keine dynamische entwicklung haben also
das ist doch eine realitätsverweigerung
wir mussten diesen entwurf vorlegen weil
eben nichts vorbereitet worden ist von
ihnen und der vorgänger regierung und
vom bundesgesundheitsminister der in
diesem sommer gesagt hat 'jetzt können
[Applaus]
die rollen von opposition und regierung
werden gerade neu verteilt aber bevor es
diese neue regierung gibt muss man sich
in vielen themen erst noch einig werden
vor allem in sachen klimaschutz beispiel
die subventionen im verkehr
steuerliche förderungen für
berufspendler für dieselfahrer oder
dienstwagen inhaber welche subventionen
wollen die ampel parteien ausknipsen für
welche gibt es weiterhin einen
freifahrtschein es knirscht die grünen
fordern nun klimaschädliche subventionen
im verkehrsbereich massiv abzubauen
es macht keinen sinn auf der einen seite
klimaschutz mit milliarden steuergelder
zu fördern und auf der anderen seite die
klima verschmutzung die befeuerung der
klimakrise dann auch mit milliarden
steuergelder zu fördern dass es wieder
nicht fahrrad fahren und kräftig in die
pedale treten und gleichzeitig die
bremse ziehen ist auch klar der fall ich
vom rad
beispielsweise die pendlerpauschale die
steuerliche absetzbarkeit von
fahrtkosten für den weg zur arbeit gilt
kritikern als klimaschädlich weil sie
auch die nutzung des autos begünstigt
doch hier stellt fdp chef lindner ein
stoppschild auf
subventionsabbau darf nicht zu einer
steuererhöhung für die arbeitende mitte
werden wie es bei der pendlerpauschale
der fall wäre
gerade auf dem land ist das auto für
pendler noch existenziell und so wirft
die pauschale neben der klima auch die
soziale frage auf die pendlerpauschale
generiert verkehr und ist damit
klimaschädlich wenn sie sich anschauen
wer von der pendlerpauschale profitiert
dann sind das die oberen
einkommensschichten wir würden das
instrument so umbauen dass die unteren
einkommensschichten davon wirklich
profitieren können und gleichzeitig
würden wir so einen beitrag zum
klimaschutz leisten sozial ausgewogen
marktliberal und klimafreundlich will
die mögliche ampelkoalition sein im
bereich verkehr an subventionen muss sie
dieses kunststück erstmal auf die straße
bringen über den richtigen weg zum
klimaschutz diskutieren nicht nur die
ampel parteien in glasgow streiten über
200 staaten über die abschaffung
ineffizienter subventionen für öl gas
und kohle die grünen fühlen sich
bestätigt jetzt sind sie aber nicht mehr
opposition also möglicherweise bald
nicht mehr das wird denn der
kohleausstieg mit dem grünen garantiert
früher kommen können sie das heute abend
so ankündigen ja ja und wenn die beiden
anderen nicht mitgehen würde es dann
eine ampelkoalition brechen
dann könnte so eine koalition nicht
zustande kommen aber wir haben uns im
sondierungs papier ja bereits darauf
verständigt weil ansonsten würden wir ja
bestehendes völkerrecht brechen
auf der zielgeraden werden verhandlungen
öfters mal noch so richtig spannend da
steht dann plötzlich alles zur
diskussion wir schalten an den ort des
geschehens nach berlin vor die
hamburgische landesvertretungen dort ist
mein kollege gerd joachim von fallois
vor ort und offenbar gibt es viele
menschen um sie herum die den
verhandlern einiges mit auf den weg
geben wollen was ist da los geht
ja hier sehr viel los hunderte von
demonstranten von verschiedenen
organisationen hinter mir sehen sie ja
zb hier gerade die verhandlungsführer
immer wenn hier einer der 21
verhandlungsführer lang gekommen ist
dann war ja ein mords kracht eben kam
als letzter noch christian lindner
gemeinsam mit anton hofreiter das sind
bilder die auch vermitteln sollen dass
man bei den ampel verhandlungen die
heute in die entscheidende phase treten
eben nach wie vor seite an seite gehen
was man sagen kann ist alle drei sind
gewillt das ganze zum abschluss zu
bringen aber die hürden so hören wir
sind doch noch ganz schön groß egal wie
groß die hürden waren oder sind egal wie
lang die to do liste der künftigen
regierung ist 24 november 20 21 15 uhr
der koalitionsvertrag wird vorgestellt
ja große unruhe aufgekommen hier in den
letzten sekunden das heißt die überhaupt
protagonisten der pressekonferenz sind
angekommen hier in diesem event &
convention center im westhafen in berlin
ganz kurz mal ein wort zu den drei
generalsekretären die ja doch
anscheinend eine sehr harmonische und
wichtige aufgabe erfüllt haben richtig
war kann nicht sagen ob das eben eine
harmonisch gewesen ist da habe ich
durchaus bezweifelt aber das ergebnis
scheint ja so funktionieren dass
zumindest bei denen die verhandelt haben
große einigkeit darüber besteht dass man
es mit diesen 177 seid mal angehen kann
in dieser zwanzigsten legislaturperiode
und ich denke ihnen pressekonferenz wird
jetzt auch gleich beginnen
vorstellung des koalitionsvertrages von
spd von bündnis 90/die grünen und fdp
kurz auch ampel genannt wir wollen jetzt
ein bisschen darüber sprechen fangen an
mit olaf scholz als kanzlerkandidaten
die ampel steht
unser ziel ist das erste bündnis von rot
grün und gelb auf bundesebene zu führen
und seien der glaube an den fortschritt
und daran dass politik etwas gutes
bewirken kann
wir wollen mehr fortschritt wagen große
worte für große aufgaben bis hierhin
lief es fast reibungslos in richtung
ampel regierung trendwende und
kontinuität zufrieden mit dem was da
geliefert wurde die bewertung dessen was
tatsächlich zusammengetragen worden ist
die wird sicherlich erst in den
kommenden wochen und monaten möglich
sein nämlich dann wenn es ans
eingemachte geht wenn's ans regieren
gehe da wird diese ampel koalition wie
es auch für alle vorherigen gegolten hat
sicherlich nicht an diesem
koalitionsvertrag gemessen werden
sondern an dem was an alltag ein problem
auftritt und dann wie sie diese probleme
lösen
[Musik]